[Musique]
pour avoir la foi il faut être
charbonnier pour être mal chaussé il
faut être cordonnier pour séduire la
foule pour chanter la pêche au moule et
pour PAP la PE il faut être à Monaco et
c'est comme ça on qui mal P faut
souffrir en silence ça sert à quoi de
vouloir quitter la France quand on est
au Vern on peut pas tout à la fois si l'
et
l'opéra pas évident P cont qu n pas
content et
[Applaudissements]
rés pour être lesé jeunir faut sentir le
sale chaud pour bien dire les ver il
faut être moulin pour faire des affaires
pour avvoir pay un il faont pas pay la
PE il fautêtre à Monaco et c'est comme
ça les anglais sont britanniques les
jardins botaniques ça sert à quoi de
vouloir quitter l'Afrique quand on est
du ganaard on peut pas tout à la BO sil
laap et l'opéra on peut pas êvident
payer cont cont mais'est pas content
et pour être costaud faut manger des
épinards pour se lever t il faut pas se
coucher tard quand on est costaud faut
se mettre un beau costard il faut pas la
peau il faut NRE à Monaco et c'est comme
ça comme disait la fontaine mironon
Mirontaine ça sert à quoi de vouloir
quitter la scène quand on ne vous
retient pas on peut pas tout à la fois
sil l'apéro et l'opéra on peut pas c'est
évident pay cont cont n'est pas content
[Musique]
et